i have we talked about this before is it
a design flaw if
it is um
designed kind of with one ideal outcome
in mind or one path in mind but you
could also get through it this way
that's calling microtransactions the the
main problem that people have is when
it's the pay to win
if it's like hey i don't want to i want
to level up quicker
then sure you can take take the shortcut
or you want to do this really really
hard what if you did like grounded level
on on last of us the game is meant to be
played
by just you know well different you know
levels of difficulty
i chose a really hard way to do it not
the ideal way is that bad is that a
design flaw that's a positive giving
players more options is always a
positive i would think
but in the case of bioshock
if you have no way to telegraph in
advance to the player you're choosing a
hard choice yeah
that's the difference between options
into the difficult path versus just luck
with the drone got you right
yeah i mean if if i
if i
like um
uh deus ex
was famous really thought you said dave
six day of sex classic sex guy got a lot
of [ __ ] in high school sex but also got
laid a lot
um
deus ex was uh what did you say
was sorry
sort of famous as a as we're already
talking over awesome i just want to
point that out to all the commenters and
you do if you're welcome this is for you
it's a good fit go on austin beautiful
go ahead so we're so on brand
you know what i always thought was
interesting about deus ex they were kind
of they were kind of easy options built
in
you get different difficulties
now and it still tickles us
i don't think uh it's i think it's risky
um
can't i like better when i was the host
and i could meet people
[Laughter]
so yes in that game
famously which one
deus ex
without the machina but implied
the first
um you mean the first one
yes the original the og 2000 or 2001 i
think uh 2000.
um
[Music]
that uh
that game gave you obviously widely
divergent options it gave you it gave
you the like do you want to be a hacker
who sneaks into the base do you want to
be a tank who like gets a rocket
launcher and blows the door off and
fights all the guys when the alarm goes
off do you want to be the
the like stealth ninja go through the
air ducts with a tranquilizer you know
like crossbow blah blah blah
and
they all
came with their own ramifications there
wasn't one that was like oh you chose
the one that's insanely hard and it's
like impossible to do and you wouldn't
have known that they all
the aspiration was
there's total agency some might be
harder for you like you might if you're
a shooter person
the tank thing is for you but if you're
like i'm all about stealth
uh then that's that you're getting so
you can you can like lean into the thing
that you're naturally better at
right like which would be inspired by
deus ex anyway and thief well i guess
part of it is that all the same team as
well yeah i would say players get to
choose
the difficulty like you're choosing
every single level how difficult you
want it to be like if you play through
dishonored and you're trying to get the
like least amount of rats possible you
are opting in to the hardest difficulty
without it being like literally the ai
is harder it's every single mission
you're making the choice by
i was just playing um frostpunk did you
ever play that uh
uh 11-bit guys who made this war of mine
yeah it's really great and and they they
straight up tell you in the ui like
it'll go um
not enough of your people have warm
housing uh and so here are
three objectives and there and it shows
you it the ui it makes explicitly clear
this is the harder one
therefore the highest reward um you know
like like if you if you if you promise
to the townspeople i'm gonna heat every
home within two days
um the game is telling you you've chosen
the harder thing but obviously it comes
with a higher reward and if you fail on
your promises to your people the penalty
for doing so is also a lot harder
to this war of mine
tonally emotionally they're very similar
they're like the most depressing
agonizing uh uh sort of like staring
staring the apocalypse in the face but
this war of mine
uh there's a frostburg is is kind of
overtly like a city builder
um in the context city survival game
basically right yeah yeah
there's a very small element of that to
this war of mine as you like soup up
your house
uh you know that you have to kind of
like you know go find supplies and
reinforce your
doors and blah blah and get
and get food and whatever and this game
has all of that but you are also
constantly like you're sending out
you know scouts and you're you're
figuring out your food supply you're
you're trying to decide do i invest in
this resource or that resource to the ex
to the to the exclusion of others do i
let in like one of the things that i
absolutely love that this war of mine
also does a variation of that's just
such a brilliant like how do you lead in
a time of absolute catastrophic disaster
is it goes refugees have found your town
there are 60 of them
um but 40 of them are sick
uh do you let in everyone do you let in
only the healthy do let in no one and
all of those
have wildly different
impacts and it's one of those where
you're like
i only take healthy people sorry the
rest of you can go [ __ ] die because
we're gonna we're like you will you will
end up killing all of us if we have to
take care of you
and like the game puts in such sharp
relief this war of mine did too i was
blown away at how that game
felt so dreary i would say that is one
of the most depressing games i've ever
played and i really enjoyed it really
really enjoyed it but when you play
through it and you're making those
choices and you're thinking about the
like similar realities of those
situations it is [ __ ] depressing
yeah
yeah and i think that this war of mine
obviously the premise being that you're
a civilian in a war zone just trying to
figure out how to stay alive whereas
frostpunk is this like the world has
ended
and everyone's just trying to live so
that puts the moral decisions an
interestingly different frame of
references because it's like
you know
uh this war of mine imagines that the
you know like it to me it doesn't it
doesn't suggest that the world has ended
it's you're just you're trapped in a in
an active war zone yeah
um and so like when you come across a
house that has like the elderly couple
who just want to be left alone and
you're like
i'm going to murder you for your food
like
that is a that is a pretty unambiguously
immoral choice in the context of a game
like
this war of mine whereas in frostpunk
the equivalence that they make i somehow
i feel like it's it's
it invites you to feel more easily
justified when you're like
what's the endgame though it's it is the
end of the world
um i don't know i love these games they
put you in this similar type of thing
like similar and it is an interesting
way to make things difficult like i said
without it just being the ai is harder
like it's
it's uh papers please is hard not only
because you can fail really easily but
also because every choice you have to
make is a moral one that's it's actually
challenging and it gets really hard if
you try to be good like if you pay for
that please yeah yeah she's trying it
right if you try to be like a moral
actor
same with these others yeah that's also
kind of in the conceit of the game as
well right
that's the message yeah
yeah anyway simple game so good it's so
good
did you ever did you guys ever play the
drug game that was out in the 90s that
was like this simple
um
you were a drug dealer i don't know troy
i was born in 93.
well this is probably i would have been
seven six you're playing you encouraged
me to play drug games as a six-year-old
troy
someone please shout out in the comments
in australia
it was oh yeah
no sadly we won't get those comments in
real time
i think we've talked about this before
where there was this great game
drug dealer video game i'm gonna just
yeah you were a drug dealer and you had
to you wanted to buy it's a basic
economy
wars drug wars there you go buy low sell
height
how about this
initial release year 84
no
yeah they didn't change the uh the ai or
the ui of it at all it was just like
well there was a player begins with two
thousand dollars and 100 spaces in their
trench coat i actually feel like i
played this i played the [ __ ]
strategy game yeah
so you would be like okay
uh well you sold the most drugs to pay
off a loan shock yep and what you can do
is go back and borrow more money you're
like meth is really cheap right now so
you can go buy that meth cheap but then
you now own a loan shark and they could
come after you if you don't pay them
often enough time or you could accrue
too much interest or the cops can find
out where you are they raid and they
steal everything actually if you went
and made that now and actually like
could put in the narrative design and
you did that with like breaking bad the
game you could make a really interesting
i couldn't that wouldn't work well quite
brand at all but like well it just
doesn't fit like arsenal no i get that
like from yeah
thomas was a drug dealer thomas is a
drug dealer
thomas i just realized i'm just a bit
too square that's what i'm saying i'm a
bit too square
i just realized why i know this game
this was a game that was it's it's
like betrays its 80s origin as a dos
game i played this on my
calculator uh like you know those
graphing calculators uh
i
didn't even know you could do that the
only game that i played was hey what's
this eight zero zero eight five look
what i did that was the games that i
made a lot like before everyone had a
computer alarm we would often have the
graphics calculators at school which
would have like a really
almost like a tamagotchi screen like a
really low quality screen but you could
play
well i did grow up without a computer
i did have a fancy calculator but they
didn't have [ __ ] video games on them
how did schools allow that
they didn't they definitely didn't allow
drugs drug wars yeah i mean it's not
like you were
austin was a rebel he was playing he was
playing by his own rules it was inspired
by a game called star trader has anyone
heard of that
yeah star trader 1974
yeah
i don't know that one it's like a
prototypical space trading name it says
text-based basic game star trader drug
wars was originally an ms-dos program
created by john e dell in 1984. it was
actually very interesting the player
began over 2000 100 spaces in their
trans trench coat and no weapons
now i might have to make that as a hobby
game and release it under a different
name
or don't do this
do something else what's something that
you can be really nice about
puppy
puppy wars yeah
that would no puppy wars would get
really dark really fast
what was that teddy bear game back there
what it was like
there's a bed right there why is your
head
i don't know what's wrong with him he's
broken
oh well
visual podcast everybody
yeah make sure there's audio
uh
the audio listeners get to decide which
of the three of us you were referring to
it's true
he's broken
i i legitimately have not thought about
games on
the calculator in 20 plus years until
this moment and it was just like a flood
of
because you had the classics like tetris
and all those had been ported as well
they were very friendly
i didn't even have to take a floppy disk
with her in her backpack i did have
floppy disks i was in the floppy disk
era so i didn't do floppy disks i
submitted assignments on poppies i'm not
not i played
when i was a kid you had one floppy disk
and that was your floppy disk you didn't
submit they were too expensive oh we had
multiple journals no you erased it you
had one you had one disc and you reused
it yeah yeah
backslash erase
like
oh man i remember a little yellow i had
a little yellow plastic wallet for it so
so i actually never had these oh my god
i could not thought about that for 20
years i never had the floppy floppy disc
five and a half they were never floppy
and i just assumed that that was not a
real thing until someone was like no
that's why it's called a floppy disk
they weren't always solid and i was like
i remember the vinyl one like if you go
watch war games and he's like hey i'm
going to play a new game and he pulls
out this [ __ ] foot long disc and
slams it shut and like you know
that was real
that was what's before that was
fictional
to save us the comments as well it is a
floppy disk it was just in a hard case
the one you had a true story just just
to save us like the 200 it was five
quarters three and a half right isn't
that right five and a quarter three and
a half it's three and a half on the
smaller what's it five and a quarter
that sounds right i might be wrong but
yeah yeah
uh three and a half was the t
and then what about because the five and
a half was the one that we had in our um
the bbc micro
which was socialized computing there you
go
so every school got like a cheap
computer basically when i was a kid five
and a half and three and a half how did
i have to get games onto the calculators
so it says
how did you do how did the games get
onto the calculators you have to you had
to get a you had to uh well that was one
option you you could actually literally
uh
replicate the code that some kids did
that but there also was at some point
those calculators did have
um like a cable that you could oh so you
could sort of tether like a link cable
yeah like some ultra precursor to a usb
cable essentially you remember back then
as well these games were like 200 lines
of code so you used to get magazines and
you could kind of type them in from
blacker magazines i remember doing that
honestly program is these days
somebody would have to start with the
with the um
typing in manually and then it would be
calculator to calculator from that point
forward what the i don't know how long
people learn to code typing things in
and [ __ ] it up and having to fix it i
love how this is all somehow an offshoot
of the airship mission
uh
from infinite that like we're sort of
sort of one step at a time somebody
needs to someday make a v you know an
indiana jones the like red the red light
tracing the
cities we need to have like topics that
show
troy you did say prince of persia and
thus piqued my interest uh but i don't
remember in what context you said prince
of persia prince of persia and karateka
those were like my
go-to games i mean i remember so vividly
coming back home and to me
just like going level by level i mean it
wasn't like
i i felt like games lasted longer but
that i know going back now it's like no
they weren't you know we were just
working i feel like i played ocarina of
time and majora's mosque for a decade
yeah i might like it feels like they
were infinite
i also don't feel like we played games
for as long of set
i was different so i if it was a pc game
i would play it in maybe shorter
sessions over longer periods of time if
it was a console game because of the way
that i grew up i didn't have a console i
had a pc because my dad was in that
business and so i i can't see you
playing video games right am i
remembering that no no no was it that
they were
gotcha your parents were
yeah i wasn't allowed to play confidence
you'll waste your life on video games
which is something i've taken great
pleasure bringing up every christmas or
well you're still doing it mom and dad
um i hope they're still just holding the
parenting advice built
when are into that
to get a real job mike
um
because they're from florida for some
reason stupid but the
the console situation was such that all
growing up either i went to different
friends a house who had different
consoles so like you know so and so
would have the atari and and this person
would have the sega or whatever um
or if i was lucky like if it was a
special occasion or like my birthday
then we could go to the video store
and i would rent the whole thing and
bring that back home and it would come
with one game
i couldn't get another one it would rent
one game and so i'd like made terrible
mistakes like i'm gonna run batman game
woof just like okay or i'm just gonna
get you know superman 64. superman 64
gave me the best game ever batman for me
was like wait a minute so it's
castlevania with the batman skin
and terrible like pretty much yeah
favorite right now that's where i fell
in you know to playing chrysalis and and
that was like nobody told me you're
supposed to go play legend of zelda i
was like i don't know c comes forward l
and that's what i got
um
but those i i feel like if if i had a
console i had 24 hours to play that as
much as i could and so i would just
just hardcore but it was nintendo 64. so
i was renting one game a week and we
were only allowed one and they often had
other people save files on them
um and sometimes i would just start from
their save file and i missed that a lot
because i felt like i was experienced
i'm sure i would have said this on the
show before i feel like i was
experiencing somebody else's memories
and i didn't know who the last kid who
played the game was
wow yeah so we just pick it up and i'd
see their name and then i'd like often
see their name not for every game and
then see where they were in this world
and like be like what did this kid get
up to and i feel like i like found that
so exciting every time before that's a
great story
yeah
this is one that buy used books that are
severely discounted because there's some
people having notes in them yeah it's so
good
yeah i love it
now you just have to download them
the play watch listen 2.0 with four
other people in a decade
is gonna be somebody being like
cds used
video games on them no
but then against me is what troy just
said about not knowing like
i really miss not knowing stuff or not
being able to immediately find out stuff
it sucks being an omniscient genius is
what you're saying i have a theory
no
i have a theory like we have with the
internet we all do like i remember as a
kid discovering metal gear solid and
having no idea what it was playing it
and it being weird and surreal and just
loving it if i'd have been able to like
google 20 reviews of it before i played
it that would have been very different
that was how i played themselves we are
all omniscient now and it's weird it's
it's weird talking to someone who grew
up without remembering the time before
the internet because they just can't
comprehend of the idea that i've only
got to have an argument in the pub
yeah so like we have to look it up
you just as a you you have to accept
that you would know something you'd have
a disagreement with someone about a
basic historical fact and because
neither of you could be asked to go to
the library you just accept that you
didn't know like it was that's something
i'm never going to learn this
yeah i don't i will never know the
answer i guess yeah
oh yeah
just that i bought it i saw
i saw like a tweet from somebody that
said this game is amazing or something
like really broad and totally
non-spoilery
non-substantive in any sense i don't
know anybody that bought it day one i
know everybody that bought it word of
mouth because somebody told them you
have to play this game and there was no
set up it's just playing i think it was
i would say i played it
well in this case i think the only i
don't remember when i played it but it
has to have been day one because i was
so
i had no idea what i was getting into
other than i was familiar with limbo i
guess
and um
that same thing actually happened with
her story as well and both of those are
like were like magical experiences to me
because i just stepped in going
the [ __ ] is this and her story was a
recommendation for me as well
probably from me i was a little bit like
that with inscriptions streamed from the
rooftops because i got a code from
devolver i didn't know anything about
the game and i was like it's i recall
that i recommended that yeah you
recommended it
i think i didn't play her story i don't
think until i was on the baptist
committee there were so many games
really you have to play this and i was
like okay [ __ ] that's what i love about
doing the baftas is it forces me to
catch up on sam's like doing judges
because we can just google [ __ ]
surely human invention is slowed down
because we can just access a solution to
almost every problem and see what
somebody else is invented there is no
necessity so there is no mother of a
video but that's like well that's your
attitude craftiness has been lowered
because you can just look it up and then
nobody's boxing idea
is invention so this is this here we go
this is proper play watch list i'm about
to start like a half hour debate i'm not
excited for it okay
is invention the result of a genius
moment of of eureka
or is it an iterative process where you
build on control of others because you
could argue google makes it much easier
and faster to become expert in the
current state of something to the point
where you can iteratively improve on it
so like you can learn how to do when you
skill much faster
that's invention or
yeah i would say i would say all
invention is iterative based on you
don't it's it's a it's a depends how
iterative i suppose but my thing is i
think that
let's play watch this in conversation
now
invention is iteration potentially but i
guess my logic is is not that it's a
spark of genius invention uh at least
would have
come from a need
there's something there's a need that
you are trying to fill and thus you come
up with a solution to the problem so you
introduced the internet reduces need
no it it reduces your need to figure it
out because somebody else already has so
you just go buy it you just ask
that's a net win though because that
basically frees up a negative actually
but that frees you up to go and invent
the thing that no one's invented yet
right yeah like you're not spinning your
wheels doing a thing that someone else
two towns over has already solved like
you can google it in five seconds
figure out the answer and then now
you're free to actually do something
novel it's an i will see of
inventiveness theoretically
yeah i i mean i know that from a sheer
patent and whatnot standpoint
were
i remember reading once this was
probably 20 years ago that i read this
too which means it's probably
doubled since then
they said something like 95 of all
inventions ever
created in the in human history were
made since the beginning of the 20th
century because the rate of progress is
so exponential
um once you get everyone fed once you've
covered basic needs survival is
published people can make a [ __ ] mesh
wi-fi router
yeah wi-fi sticks as it were and it it
spreads and it it it's gonna spread
across every
every dimension um
and
i'm sorry
no well like this is this is um this is
why
like
they say the the well that's gonna be
real listen to a totally different
direction each individual iphone a new
invention
i would have thought the iphone was the
invention
right i would even vote that that was
what it is the smartphone was the
invention that's an iteration i i see
where mike's coming from i remember this
is going to seem like it's unrelated but
the the wright brothers didn't just they
won the first person to try and make a
play they were just no davinci was off
doing that [ __ ] you know people down the
road they weren't like
wake up one morning and go i'm going to
invent you
like
every every like we we deify right we
take narratives and we simplify them the
you know the light bulb yes was invented
by one person but then there were 20
others and the guy who invented it isn't
the guy you associate with that but is
that not an iteration on the candle
hmm well i mean it would i assume
someone it is
different enough that it has to have
been invented
well i i agree but i i see what mike's
saying it's like every
every quote invention is somehow
derivative of something it's finding a
better way to do something even the
wheel is like a better means of
transportation because the square just
it's sold like hotcakes but they haven't
even been hotcakes it's gonna be like
what about the spear but that's just an
iteration on the stick
yeah
guys so put something pointing on the
end of it here's what i was gonna say
are you saying that though with the idea
being that it is
like
i know this is not how you would phrase
it but to the sort of the to the dish to
the to the diminishment of the inventor
that theirs is not actually something
totally new
yes no i i had a conversation once we
were at a wrap party and i found myself
at uh it was it was a wrap party for a
movie that uh um
diamond phillips lou diamond phillips i
don't know if you guys remember this but
my very first thing that i did
um
it did it didn't matter uh uh
i was right across from from jimmy
fallon
and we were having this conversation
well
kind of but no because i was talking to
this person and i kept noticing that
jimmy was just kind of listening in on
our conversation we were talking about
is there any original music out or is
everyone just basically trying to
rewrite hey jude um you know as many
times as they can like what what what is
there any original music
and i i saw him kind of look over he's
like jimmy what do you think and he goes
what
i was like instantly mad i think i've
told this story before i was like is
there any original music goes tom waits
man and went back to his conversation i
was like
yeah but that's not necessarily pop
music but i i think we have talked about
this before because austin i i think
paris wouldn't credit hey jude as like
an innovation he'd he'd point to five
different things that influenced him
well paul mccartney would say that there
is no white album without pet sounds and
so
i i look at this and i say there's eight
notes in their respective sharps and
flats and they're doomed to be repeated
so what's novel about it is how you use
those
the perfect example that that
link that you sent me the other day
that's hilarious what's this guy's name
tim what
tim mentioned tim mentioned oh yeah i
like to sing an f sharp
without even hearing the clip just the
setup and me hitting a note people were
like that's hilarious
that to me is novel and innovative but
you got to bring it back homie you got
walls make some floating shelves
but i i do think that um
i've never thought about it in terms of
what mike is talking about but i guess
there is
bible quote there's nothing new under
the sun
there's there's just an iteration or an
innovation on something that makes it
easier so
google is is an innovation on top of
yeah my argument is it's fine to use
your light bulb candle thing which
obviously skips a few steps but let's
use that because it's a nice
illustration right it is easier now to
become a candle expert to the extent
that you could make a better light bulb
yeah that's what i'm saying is you
there's more resources you can build
it's you can build on the shoulders of
giants faster because you can go i've
got the full sum of human knowledge
available to me if i know the right
question to ask we've had this what's
interesting culturally is yeah like that
video games the the idea of executing
upon coming up with the idea and
executing upon it the first time is the
hardest everyone who does it after that
has it way easier and thus is opened up
for opportunity absolutely different
that's why games keep getting better and
denser and cheaper to make because we
all learn from each other we all is that
true cheaper to make it cheaper to make
yeah
so
budgets may be higher
but
the
cheaper to make the same car if you were
trying to impossible to make if you were
trying to make turok for the n64 right
now you could do it with three guys
that's all right
you if you would one place you have to
yeah
upload that to steam
yeah
well but you wouldn't do that because if
you're trying to make a game that was
equivalent to rock now you'd make a big
triple a shooters also you're right
costs go up even unreal
in theory going to help a lot of devs
level the playing field yeah i also
would argue that budgets have on average
come way down because there's five
billion more teams than there used to be
um and like how does that equate
well because the number like the the
the sony and ubisoft and microsoft
etcetera affiliated studios
that have seen their budgets rise
it's not like there's 50 000 first party
sony studios all of a sudden
whereas on steam every day there are
more games uploaded per day than 10
years ago per year
um so i would say that that
average costs if you probably weigh it
down
the industry-wide average budget of any
game is probably substantially lower
than it is
democratization
is it's probably [ __ ] insane i have
no millions
that is such an interesting thing to
especially all actors perk up and really
honestly i think anyone that's trying to
get into this industry it goes back to
the conversation that we were having
was it last week but no video i can't
remember
where the
yeah it was last week
i didn't see it
um
the notion of an atom baby
um the notion that you know just the or
the assumption that games just make
millions and millions of dollars um it's
very still a very sensitive subject but
i remember during the strike that was
the conception of actors coming in just
like these guys are making millions of
dollars where's my end where's my cut
and it's like
if you if you want if you want that
then sure we can have the whole argument
of whether or not you deserve or not or
or should have access to that absolutely
but
there's a whole other subset of
questions and conversations that we have
to have in order for you to understand
that and and the first thing that i i
would recommend to you is go to the
developer
just just go spend a day
at any dev anywhere making any game and
then come back and go
i still deserve more money than that
they're making i just
if if you feel you do not be a socialist
that's not what union that's not what
when a union uh we're not talking about
unions though we're talking about
residuals which i think are can easily
residuals when when when workers ask to
be paid more that doesn't mean that they
they think they deserve more than the
person next to them they think the
person next to them should also be
asking
that wasn't specifically there was no
awareness of because the the
conversation that followed was well if
we if we do this then
then the people that are making that we
have to do that too then it was like oh
then give that to them as well but it
wasn't the
it wasn't like hey let's rise all boats
it was i want my ship to come in and
yeah and that should be the rise all
boats yeah that's fair i think as well
acting it's an interesting one because
there's definitely there's a different
role that an actor plays in a game than
they do in the film in terms of what the
ending is for them
it's just it's a nuanced thing isn't it
yes and that's that that to me is is why
conversation and discourse is so
important and being able to educate
yourself as far as like these guys are
not the notion is like they're driving
lamborghinis and they're driving
ferraris and they're making millions of
dollars like
at the same time that's really awkward i
tried it once i just couldn't do it
the maintenance alone is i think there
is two steering wheels that's the
challenge stuck in the middle
i think there's a
broadly
poorly understood relationship between
risk and reward
and
there's
these conversations around residuals and
and um
because there was a whole musicians
union equivalent to that conversation as
well sure um and i i i find that um
uh
there's this i don't know what to
attribute it to but
but um
there's this
oddly
it just seems like people just don't
understand who's risking the most
um and therefore
righteously
deserving of
the greatest potential windfalls in a
given project and i'll give you an
example
well
here's a here's a timely example because
i had somebody
reach out to me
um
to license some of my music for a thing
they were making
um and like not a game it's like it was
like a youtube video
and
they
uh they i i was like sure you know i
here's here's how much that
uh will cost
and take it or leave it and they said
i'll take it
and then they
signed a contract
they used it released it
then it severely underperformed from
their hopes and they came back to me and
said i'd like to cancel the deal
and i said
so wait a minute
you're asking that i have bought into
your risk
uh
like i did i why should i i did nothing
with this
i i named a rate you owe me that rate
now if i had stood to gain a thousand
fold if it was this huge viral hit and
now i took on nothing because it didn't
do anything that would have been fair
like because i because i took a lot of
risk
yeah because i took on no risk i i i can
lay claim to absolutely nothing beyond
that which was agreed to that's your way
of mitigating your risk because you now
have a hard cost that's fixed and you
know that we're one and done you don't
get to just
change that deal after the fact that i
theoretically have done a different deal
with you which was trying to say views
right they could absolutely pay you x
per thousand views or whatever and then
they would have but then you'd have been
splitting that risk together with a with
a bigger payoff there's also just
with residuals specifically to video
games there was never a you buy the game
you buy the game
with something that is a um
whether it be something that originally
like streaming right now is like what do
we do with that and there's there's no
it's really hard way to do additional
payments unless like netflix something
that's on sky
um will be on netflix here or vice versa
to where
netflix does things where it's called a
third window which means it's originally
intended to be here but it's also going
to air here and because of that there's
advertising dollars that are surrounding
that viewing you're we're gaining
because we're showing this thing that
you're in there's an additional payment
for that or we did something that shows
up in the theaters and now it's now
viewing on hbo max so there is a second
viewing of that and it's there's you
know sponsorship money or subscription
funding or or ad money that's surrounded
by that here's an additional payment you
buy the game bam one and done there's no
additional thing unless
it becomes like games as a service so i
understand how that's what the games
industry spent last 10 years trying to
do is work out how to make those revenue
streams live on their own there is there
is an interesting
grey space there because um the way
composer royalties work
um
is from what's called public exhibitions
um the which would be your your ascap or
bmi
um in the case of the uk prs
there's a different one per the us is
the only country in the world that has
multiple uh performance royalty
organizations all the rest is one per
country and they all partner with each
other i've probably explained this to
some degree in the on the show in the
past so forgive that but
um the way that it works is
this was started by tin pan alley
composers 100 years ago a little more
than 100 years ago when uh artists would
buy sheet music of their songs and then
go sell out theaters performing their
music and and and the composer would
never see a dime and they'd go well it's
not that i want to take all their money
like they they are the performer they
did the thing but surely i should get
something if they're performing my music
so these organizations said because it's
a public exhibition um
you have to pay a royalty
uh and the way that they worked it out
was it's actually the the venue has to
pay a license so that the artist it's
it's not like they'll pass along their
license fee to as part of their
agreement with the artist presumably
like you know some kind of uh
cut off of ticket sales or whatever but
then they pay like an annual license to
an ass cap or a bmi and then they go
okay you know your song was played on
june 1st and another artist came in and
played on our stage on august 2nd or
blah blah and here is the check uh for
your cut of those evenings and and as
you can imagine
uh tv blew this into a whole new
dimension and it's how you end up with
composers
um you know if you really if you do if
you're if you're a jonathan wolfe
scoring seinfeld you're talking about
tens of millions of dollars of of back
end uh money because every time it plays
on tv you're owed a royalty and this is
the kind of thing that is never off tv
it's 24 hours a day law and order
or law and order or you know
so the the thing that's weird sorry just
real quick to finish up the thread there
is that um
of course all the composers like i'm a
member of ascap but because i
overwhelmingly work in games i get very
little from them for that work because
as you said it's one and done there have
been a few random exceptions there was
some hulu show that licensed the
character on screen was playing
assassin's creed syndicate um so i did
manage to to get
you know 12 cents uh from the like
fraction of a second that you
theoretically could hear my music
although i found the episode and i
turned it so loud and i was like boy
like
it's there but holy hell is that quiet
um but interestingly in the uk
by law they've passed a law that
is unique to the rest of the world that
that prs and sony made a deal that
sales on the playstation network in the
uk
are now under the banner of public
exhibition like showing a tv show so
playstation games that i
like they once they came to that
agreement
i i basically was they reached out to me
and were like this is can you help us
we're basically auditing records to see
what games on playstation have been sold
and we want to get you your because it
was like the banner saga suddenly now it
wasn't worth like a ton of money but if
that became industry standard practice
yeah you're basically i can't imagine
that it would i think the uk is
sort of far
more progressive in this way than a lot
of other countries and like aggressively
going after those income streams because
that's not
the case here but the the other big
wiggle area that ascap and bmi and all
those others are looking to go surely
there's something substantive to be made
here but it's really dicey territory it
was of course twitch and things
compromised that's the main thing is i
would i don't want that to happen i
don't believe that that's the move
because what you end up doing is
putting a strangle hold on what's truly
good for the industry right there's more
people that are playing games than ever
before and a lot of those people or more
people that are experiencing the gaming
culture who may end up just going like
i know some people are like i'd never
played games i watched them but then i
started playing them
i want that to be an entry point the
same reason why most publishers and
developers are like we're not going to
sue you or you know nickel and dime you
for playing our game on twitch because
you're now our marketing i was just
talking to an australian girl yesterday
who's a streamer who started playing
video games because she was watching
pewdiepie
play alien isolation and really enjoyed
it and that was her start into playing
video games and i imagine that like
people have similar stories with people
like jacksepticeye or markiplier or
whatever like i didn't realize that was
that much of a reality that that's that
is an entry point for a lot of people it
reaches to a completely different
audience and i feel like that's what our
job is i i want people it's the same
reason why neil is you know and craig
mason are making
something that was shot scored released
everything in a cinematic way in a
completely different format is because
he believes they both believe now that
the story of the last of us is good
enough that it should go to meet the
people that will never pick up a
controller that's true and i don't
believe we should be exclusive i think
that we should be as you know reaching
across
the the thing about austin's point about
risk and reward
i think it's very interesting for actors
especially like obviously actors get
paid
this is a generalization but for a
transport network tv show or film get
paid a lot but they also kind of carry
the weight of that thing more than a lot
of people behind the scenes often more
than a director so if you're an actor
and you're in a very good field
right but if the movie's bad you will be
made fun of forever forever associated
with that bad film even if it's bad
outside of your performance so
bringing your reputation to the table
right for the market much more than even
the right bringing value
we've talked about your game makes a
statement about what level of game
you're making what that game is that
they're forgetting
like
never get off the bat
it means you're releasing a video game
of choices
but like genuinely like there's there's
a value in a cache which has to factor
into the pricing of what troy charges
for his time it's not just
he's not just doing a job he is he is
also a marketing choice as well often
voice actors in games come out of the
marketing budget as well as the
development budget because we know
exactly what you're saying we know that
there's value to an actor beyond the
execution of the job at hand so
sometimes i've certainly seen that
happen i have to make decisions believe
it or not where i i do have to be
judicious in in the jobs
that um that i choose to take for for
for various reasons and number one it
could be like i can't
do this game because if i do this game
that precludes me from doing this game
and continuity yeah so it's like i
really want to hold out for this one
this may never happen
but if i do this this means 100 that i
can't do this so
every actor looking at a minor role in a
marvel movie
yeah give me daredevils
said that he did that he was offered a
smaller role and then was like wait for
something bigger and worked out pretty
well for him because otherwise you can't
really come back
my thing is not even bigger like if
daredevil were to show up in a
spider-man game
and it's all it would ever be is just a
cameo that would be great i i want to
see the daredevil game made but but
aside from that it's like i wouldn't
want to play spiderman as well i
couldn't play spiderman
but
there's uh the best teenage boy voice
troy i can't do it because i haven't
been missed i have been that that goes
to like the the yuri lowenthals and max
middleman's and
charlie schlatters and all those guys i
can't do it i i always just sound like
i'm just trying to do that like even
nolan is like
[ __ ] yeah but then you go female yeah um
oh i can get that conversation too
yeah the amount of female actresses
playing
young boys is especially an anime it's
like
so many of them it's like shakespearean
man
i will i will add one last little thing
just as another
um for actors coming up uh
no matter your situation
uh there's never a reason to take a role
if it costs you your integrity
so there's a couple people that have
approached me this is like should i do
this because i'm afraid that if i say
yes to this they could preclude me from
doing another job
if you are meant to do this then you're
gonna do it and that thing will not be
the thing that makes or breaks you so
i i would there was a situation this
week where
uh something came uh down my way and and
i was like um
i feel like you should ask this person
first and they're like you sure it's
like yeah i think you should ask this
person first and that person ended up
being like thank you that's yeah that
that that should go to me kind of thing
and
my agent was like i'm i'm i'm just gonna
let you know like for what it's worth
i'm really proud of you like and i'm
like i'm glad that i have an agent in my
corner that's going to back me up when i
say that stuff because i've been in a
situation before
years ago when when uh all of a sudden
every vo actor saw these breakdowns
coming down for futurama and they were
trying to recast everybody and it was
being used as a bargaining ship so they
could say we could get these people we
already could recast right now so people
like john dimaggio and and the whole
cast would kind of be screwed
and
to this day there are people
that audition for those roles because
they're like a gig as a gig
and people remember
and i was new in town and even then i
was like
no way and my first session with john
dimaggio
um
he was like i heard about you i was like
wow he was like well i just heard that
you
walked away from those auditions he goes
i just want to let you know i really i
really appreciate that
um so just be cautious like integrity
yeah it's hard out here and it's gonna
cost you but i just it it always will
pay into dividends um to never [ __ ]
anybody over just to get a job i mean
that applies to everything and also
applies to your situation but i think
that applies to like every vocation
right like
i don't know how that really our
industry as well is so connected yeah
[ __ ] people over everyone each other you
will [ __ ] i'm over it
well it's such a small industry like if
you've got if you build a bad reputation
then that will follow you preach
i spent years overcoming a lot of a lot
of bad behaviors that that
people still assumed well i mean you
thought like the first time we watched
you're like i think i know this guy is
and
it took you and i working together
you're like okay
he's not a total prick with me you talk
about me
i didn't think you were prick i didn't
think you were pregnant just like there
was a there was an assumption to where
it was like
i'm not taking words out of your mouth i
mean this is
i remember saying it now i was like i i
figured troy was famous and that's why
he was but then i worked with you and i
realized like you know you're a pro like
is that the i can't remember the exact
thing something like that it was like
kind of like some people just hire him
because he's the guy right now and then
it was like oh yeah he actually gives a
[ __ ] and like comes in and works hard
and yeah i never said that to anyone but
yeah i came in with that how true just
as a closing thought since i know we
gotta run
true
wrong
i'm curious how true it is how many
people
do just kind of waltz through because i
have to say i know i can't i can't
i can't say any names yet but we've
obviously been working on this musical
straight gods
and our cast is just stupid in this game
it's unbelievable
well no that's actually the point i was
gonna make they actually down to the
last person have tried their hardest and
and all like
for all of them this is not
you know like it could even just be a
short stint in the studio because their
character is reasonably small or
whatever and and some of these are are
huge names and it would be easy to make
these assumptions like they're doing us
a favor they're gonna come in it's gonna
be super path of least resistance uh
like just whatever quick easy cash for
an afternoon or a couple afternoons or
whatever and none have given that
impression that's the thing that's why i
was curious how true is this notion
that oh you know their big name so if
they do your thing they're just going to
waltz in like not really give a [ __ ]
it seems really rare certainly
i i've experienced it i've definitely
seen there are people you i've been
lucky with the people i've worked with
i'm not afraid anyone on the bus but
like you definitely do encounter the the
big deal who
knows they're a big deal and will
therefore just kind of coast on it 100
i've met but i do feel that now
by and large for the most part if there
is a even a name
that's that's in a game
it's because they're a gamer
and they like you take like rahul who
would come in and be like i'm gonna
throw the same amount of energy
preparation work craft and everything
behind
being in
um
i don't know that rahul did that with
fortnite i'm being honest
he's no he's very passionate like he's
incredible yeah but he's probably
he was great to work with
really great to work with
him
he is in fortnite he's the origin and i
keep saying you should start introducing
yourself as fortnight's the origin
because as it turns out it's a big deal
and we don't know what's happening
i i love the fact that the reason why
that would probably be his most viewed
role right for sure it's just so massive
yeah
donald trump
i'm i'm jonesy because donald muster was
like how can i get troy and bicker in my
game i'm like well
you're licensing really big properties i
don't think you need me my guys like
yeah just see if i can't do it it's like
what if we just retrofitted troy's voice
onto jones and i was like
yeah give me did the character have a
voice before no oh hmm so they all said
it was like john gimacchio played it
before
one futurama
i'm coming for you bender i'm coming for
you i'm sure i've said this before but i
think like santa monica studios hundreds
and hundreds of people i do not feel
like there is a single person at the
studio who is dead weight or thinks
they're a big shot and and is lazy about
it i just i just think you'd get fired i
just don't think it would work i don't
think you'd expect as an industry
we're a lot better at that now than we
used to be i think i know i've heard the
similar about santa monica from the
outside like there's 100 there was a
period when i came into the industry
there were a lot of lazy [ __ ]
basically and unfortunately yeah the
indus well no fortunately i guess the
industry moved on and we definitely
the expectations are now higher like and
mostly
press who sucked to like slept through
appointments and didn't show up because
they got drunk and other people that's
less common they didn't get fired
generally
work ethic and respect for your
co-workers have just become very
important in a way that they weren't
when i started my career i see games
being in the in the space where tv was
like five years ago whereas like all
those professionalized right well not
only that but it's also like it becomes
the fertile ground where i've seen
writers who were working in tv
um going i wanted this is the end the
medium that i want to be working in the
cinematographers as well it's like i i
wanted to do a film but man there's just
some really cool opportunities for us to
do something inside here so i i
definitely believe that the game space
will be
where people are coming to and therefore
it's they're
it's their dream this isn't inside you
have to you have to really want it to
especially it sounds small
a show you would hang on to for like
maybe like a movie you're gonna be there
for two three months
a show you may be working on it for like
three or four months maybe
no one is gonna be like yeah i'm gonna
sign on for two and a half years or
three years or five years of where and
turn down other gigs just so that i can
work on this they're like
this is where your passion is so it's
true
um before we go today this feels like a
terrible idea i feel like i'm rewarding
bad behavior i have a gift
that i'm going to share with you that
feel it feels like i'm doing it after
you've just you're doing a very bad job
happy accidents we bob ross the [ __ ] out
of that episode everyone talked about
how great it was at the very end
okay i have to go that was not by design
it was it was definitely glass good that
we got the reaction to the realization
that there had been on tape
don't think there's any video can you
see it oh
my god oh my god
oh my background's been updated to the
new location
okay
everyone can see this all right uh it
should have audio let me know if it
doesn't
this is supposed to be for episode 100
but uh 107. who cares same thing okay i
use a lot of towels and what i will do
is use a single swipe like get out of
the shower one pass throw it away
[Laughter]
and then you take those
that's what the robe is for i like the
thomas
yeah i will fold up those like in a nice
little like hobos bag kind of thing so
that and i would put i will put those
into the tub so they walk in they don't
have to like gather up all these things
it's just literally just grab these and
i i saw them they do this with the
sheets they take them and they bundle up
and they they kind of do a loose tie i
was like oh i'm going to do that for
them and somebody likes not that hairy
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh i want to know what you were talking
about with this old dilbert comic so bad
no i have no idea
that that's gonna be in our 200th
episode when you do that who said this
like gilbert is going to go that sounds
like a reference that i would make very
big thank you to matt ringstead for
anime us
my favorite part of that is troy trying
to dry
while under the water in the shower
not by the way
not
not untrue funny and the frustration
it's just like just beating is like why
just this paging sisyphus is like i
don't give a [ __ ]
next time that an episode
is about here's a podcast name i'll give
matt like
ten thousand dollars and have him
animate the whole episode and then we'll
have a little feature film
i kind of want to make a speaker of
myself
kind of want to make a game with them we
might be able to figure out hey on
patreon um
we will i will i will take i will take
no money if we can if we can make a play
watch listen game i will take zero
dollars the amount of requests we've had
for that are quite large uh just being
somebody who's making a game i keep
being like not that simple folks not
that simple but we could do a little
game jam type thing we could do a game
jam we could 100 make that happen i
think that would be honestly to point
out i suggested that like six thousand
years ago
i'll give you credit for that one austin
as long as you give me inscription you
piece of [ __ ] i think that we should
make that an episode that we do a game
jam and we just get to see the shitty
ideas we come up with that'd be great
i'm down i'm down and if you can go and
make it then
this sounds like a better bossman's
holiday for me i'll be honest
uh happy 107
um we have video in every bit
we will continue to have video
i love that you guys mentioned at the
end that i would be so proud of you and
then you're surprised i'm so smart
you're so smart
for the record the folder that i save
all my audio in
adam never changed it mike's is the most
hopeful wait yours says that because he
does the date i don't think i've ever
noticed no his file names are not bad
he's saying my file names are proper but
the folder
is still at them
for me it's easier
yeah the reason i we didn't go with adam
is because it means nothing to anybody
it's bad marketing it was my logic that
that when you see it
doesn't translate to any information
to be fair i don't disagree i'm just
petty
[Laughter]
i just want to win i don't actually i
don't actually think it's a better name
it's a terrible name i still have fun
at least at least one person on twitter
goes the goggles do nothing or i think
it was a comment on the video but yeah
was the person arnold schwarzenegger is
that he was they did not do this
no
they were the simpsons version of
schwarzenegger which is
reign your wolf castle
get it
is a simpsons reference come on yeah see
i didn't even know that of course you
tried to [ __ ] sneak simpsons into the
name of the show um well we got ensued
our first episode way to go i will put
the animated short up on the channel on
saturday after the podcast goes up as
well so you can see it without our
little faces laughing on the side
uh i'm alan i'm a video game writer
that's mike bible he's a video game
director you're all currently below me
so then that's also troy baker just a
bit further down that's the fact of life
that's austin wintry the whole way down
um way down the bottom composers just
way down that's where they belong
we'll see you next week bye